à l'été approche à grands pas il est il
est là pratiquement et pour la plus
grande partie d'entre nous c'est bientôt
les vacances mais certains toutefois
n'ont pas encore peut-être tout à fait
choisi définitivement leur lieu de
villégiature par goût par nécessité ou
par civisme devant rester dans les
stalles l'hexagone gérard pas bio a
voulu nous rafraîchir la mémoire sur les
possibilités qu'offrent les départements
français et sont multiples le cantal à
votre avis où se trouve le cantal deux
constats se trouvent nos tables un peu
majeur que du pain et du vin et un
couteau qu'est ce que c'est le cantal
fromage alors en france l'allier sait où
en france l'allier je pense qu'on peut
compter sur l'angleterre l'allemagne
déjà sur le pays qui sont les plus forts
aimeriez vous vivre dans leur par
exemple on met nos petits copains non je
préfère un mieux vivre quand même un peu
par le passé pourquoi on veut jetons
comme étant l' europe nv
la vie c'est beaucoup plus d accès
comparé leur envoyer les voyez vous
c'est qu'elle bassin méditerranéen où il
va s'arrêter reviens moi j'aime bien les
femmes qui sont bien en chair bien dans
leur bien dans leur peau bien dans le
camp le cul un peu gros voyez vous le
cul aussi vous parler sa pointe
c'est pour pallier un mot trivial 6 et
le bassin parisien alors ça serait quoi
ben ça serait plutôt des femmes qui ont
les hanches plus minces si je vous dis
l'ille-et-vilaine bah écoutez moi je
suis jamais allé mais je pense à bâle il
est alors je pense pas que ce soit si
les lynx a je pense pas que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui peuvent
se passer
vous imaginez comment j'imagine que cela
étant donné que c'est près de la
frontière belge
ille et vilaine si je vous dis le
loir-et-cher qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
jeudi c'est possible que quoi ce soit
cher quoi dans le loir et c'est possible
pourquoi parce que il faut pour une
surface d'ameublement il faut plusieurs
peau de bête et une grande lambeaux de
peaux de bêtes
si je vous parle de la creuse en france
qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire ça
creuse
l'assiette creuse une dent creuse et
puis je vois pas c'est tout ce que vous
voyez en france une dent creuse ou une
assiette
quelle chaîne de montagnes
connaissez-vous en france voyez déjà ce
que c'est qu'une chaîne de montagne oui
je joueur je vois ce que c'est là parce
que j'ai réussi le père mines et mais
j'en ai pour l'instant pas encore
utilisé 2 est ce que c'est qu'une chaîne
de montagne c'est ce qu'on met sur les
pneus pour pour essayer que de ne pas
déraper l'ardèche c'est quoi c'est
vraiment la provôté c'est la misère où
situeriez vous laine monsieur jaloux
c'est un cas l'endroit mois plein alors
c'est la voilà voilà
et si je vous parle du bas rhin alors le
bas rhin ces messieurs bas du dos
l'album du mal l'endroit où quoi je leur
ai une côte qui accueille le festival
dans le bas-rhin et ses ouvriers montre
un oui c'est là le bas rhin hélène vont
montrer encore ici alors laine et le
barbare
[Musique]